يصادف هذا العام مرور نصف قرن على
توقيع اتفاقية السلام الخاصة بحرب فيتنام، وقد
عاد ما يقرب من 600
أسير حرب أمريكي الأسبوع الماضي، وقد
اجتمع بعض هؤلاء الرجال معًا لتبادل الذكريات
والاحتفال بأنهم على قيد الحياة.
الرقيب كين
والينجفورد آنذاك
والآن لم أر هذا الرجل خارج
جنازة واحدة ذهبنا إلى أحد
رفاقنا منذ 50 عامًا، هذه هي المدة التي
مرت منذ إطلاق سراحهم من
معسكر سجن في الغابة
[موسيقى]
والآن نعود معًا للاحتفال بذلك  نصف
قرن من الاستماع، لا أريد أن أمنعك
من تناول العشاء، إنه أمر جيد
لأنني جائع
ثم إنه سيء ​​حقًا [
موسيقى]
73. هم ومئات من الأسرى الآخرين
تناولوا العشاء مع الرئيس في
البيت الأبيض أبدًا  هل كان البيت الأبيض
أكثر فخرًا مما هو عليه الليلة بسبب
الضيوف الذين لدينا أكثر مني
بعد 50 عامًا بالضبط من هذا اليوم هنا
في مكتبة ريتشارد نيكسون، نفس
الطعام، سلطة نبتون، لحم البقر،
كعكة الفراولة، لم يعد هناك الكثير من الرجال على
قيد الحياة  للاستمتاع،
اعتبرنا فيشر نيكسون الرجل
المسؤول حقًا عن إعادتنا إلى المنزل،
وحتى يومنا هذا نحن نحب الرجل، كل
رجل على هذه الطاولة كان محتجزًا في نفس
معسكر أسرى الحرب، حيث أصيب سميث ووالينجفورد
في عام 1972 بجروح بالغة وتم
أسرهما بعد المعركة الوحشية.
وقع انفجار كبير في بحيرة لوخ نين، وشعرت وكأن نصف
رأسي قد انفجر، كنت لا
أدري قبل أن أذهب إلى فيتنام،
تحويلات Battlefield،
أنت تنظر إلى ما أنا عليه الرجل الذي
عرفك، ولن يتم القبض علي أبدًا لأن
ذلك  لم يحدث إلا أن الخاسرين
أصابتني رصاصة من طراز AK في ساقي أوقعتني
أرضًا من طريق آر بي جي التي كانت
تستهدف صدري وانطلقت من خلفي
وأوقعتني خارجًا كانوا محتجزين في أقفاص نمور من
الخيزران اشرح لي ما هو
قفص النمر  هو أنه إذا سبق لك أن ذهبت إلى
حديقة الحيوان
وشاهدت حيوانات في أقفاص، فإنهم يضعون
هذه الأخشاب مقاس
5 × 6 و5 × 5 في كعكة داخل قفص به
باب صغير، وكان عليك أن تعلم أن الانحناء
للأسفل للاحتجاز في تلك الأقفاص
لأنهم لن يفعلوا ذلك  كما قيل لهم،
لم ندلي بأي تصريحات، ولم نكتب
رسائل، ولم نقم بأي بث،
ولا يوجد شخص يبلغ من العمر 50 عامًا، هؤلاء الرجال
ممتنون كل يوم، إنه يوم عظيم،
لا يهمني كيف يبدو الطقس في
الخارج، ولا أشعر بأي ندم على الرائد المتقاعد
مارك زيبو سميث وور.
هذا ما أفعله
في الخارج